Bob Uecker has called the fourth-most
games on radio in baseball history he's
trailing the retired Vin Scully VIN did
it 67 years another Dodger icon
Jamie Garin 62 years and running I
should say Jaime Jaron Kansas City's
Denny Matthews 52 years and counting and
Bob is ready for his 50th year calling
Brewers games in Bob Uecker mr. baseball
joining us on the program
hi Bob how are you how you doing I'm
doing okay no pressure on you other than
I wanted to have some fun with baseball
and there hasn't been anything fun with
baseball's of late so how are you doing
how's your morale I'm doing okay I'm
glad we're going back to work
and it'll be my 65th year overall in
baseball you know as a player if you
want to say that and and of course
calling the games here in Milwaukee I
worked a couple of I worked a couple of
seasons with the Braves with Milo
Hamilton and Ernie Johnson before but
brought me back to Bud Selig brought me
back to Milwaukee but other than that
I'm hanging around and I'm waiting to go
back to work I just saw where your
official batting average in your career
was 199 7 I you know that I couldn't a
lot of my sponsors would be upset if it
dropped below 200 because at that time
it tied me with another sports great
averaging 200 or better for a 10-year
period and that was hauling boards on
cars but but were you the Mendoza line
before the Mendoza line Bob he's got a
job in baseball now I think she works
for the Mets
doesn't she that's it that's a different
Mendoza okay and tell me if this is
right did you get traded did your
baseball career get extended because you
were
a good Clubhouse guy oh yeah I mean
longer he's gotta be done I mean for a
couple of extra bucks a month I was
making I was making below the minimum
you know that and and selling other
players equipment got me a couple of
bucks doing laundry there's a lot of
things that you can do without playing I
actually thought it was an infringement
when they asked me to play a game but I
thought you got traded to the Cardinals
because you were gonna backup McCarver
and you might have had a better arm but
they liked your personality and and I
think arm wise I had one on each side
which wasn't but yeah to back up Timmy
who's remained a great friend and of
course you know we win a World Series
that year when I got traded to st. Louis
and I'm not I'm not gonna say anything I
didn't win one before something had to
be working right when you when you were
the first one went on on Carson first
time you were on there were you still
playing baseball no I was I was done and
as a matter of fact the first show I did
what Johnny was in New York they had
moved to the west coast yet I think it
was in 1970 maybe 69 or 70 how'd you end
up on the show I I had been friends with
a great trumpeter one of the legendary
trumpeters of all time Albert and I did
a couple of jobs with him I was
traveling Alex Karras was a guy that's
work with he was there because he was a
great player I was a I was the wind up
speaker but I did a couple of jobs
without hurt and he told me he was going
to get me on a Tonight Show and I said
oh yeah sure well I got a call from The
Tonight Show about two weeks later and I
went to New York I had a I had audition
with a talent guy and he I went in his
office and he said what'd you do I said
nothing I'm good so well let me see some
of your stuff or let me hear what you're
going to talk about so I did a couple of
things you
tell him we'll call you back till he
clearly comes back to New York and I did
the show with Johnny and I remember the
one thing that was funny about it dan
was at the end of the show one you know
he's saying goodnight and everything I
heard Johnny say to head after we we
said goodnight did that guy really play
baseball I went back two weeks later and
did another one and then I went no got
to be kind of a pretty regular you know
with with Johnny we had a great
relationship and I did but I still do
with Doc Severinsen and you know a lot
of the guys in the band I would over and
do it tonight show when we were playing
an anti on when the Brewers were playing
an Anaheim I would go over and do it
Tonight Show and then come back I get
back maybe in the third inning and some
of the bad guys would come up and sit in
the booth at the ballpark so it was I
had a great time with the night shows
all the time how did that change your
life well raised my salary by 220
dollars a month that was the big thing
but um I had a pension you know the
Screen Actors Guild so I wasn't worried
about baseball anymore but I did you
know I stuck around baseball at six
years I guess had a great time doing it
made great great you know really great
friendships and including yourself and
your crew there but all of you know if I
ever had a good year it would really
screwed me up later a couple of times I
got off the good starts I had to go in
the tank well yeah nobody there's
nothing funny about getting off to a
good start
you know like batting 225 is not funny
but 197 that's funny
wearing a uniform at home Carson
introduced you one time when you think
of great baseball players a lot of names
come to mind Bob Uecker is not one of
them
right and he called you mr. baseball
yeah and that kind of stuck around he's
he I have those I have a great picture
at home here of him Elston Howard and
Roger Maris in New York and and Mickey
all with Johnny and he he's got a got a
Yankee uniform on and it looks awful on
him the way he's wearing it the Sox are
you know down on the ground but he's
with them and he had a glove and I think
he tried to throw batting practice to
those guys at Yankee Stadium really yeah
oh yeah yeah he was a great guy to work
with Dan and I like I said before I
always had a great time with him he
treated me I never got bumped off the
show you know I always stayed on and
somebody else got bumped but we had it
we had a good relationship now in fact I
went out to the University of Nebraska
he built a he built a studio and a
really nice building out there for you
know people who want to get involved in
movies television whatever it may be and
I went out there as part of the opening
with that with our with our owner mark
at Kannagi it was a matter of fact and
had a great time they did a lot of shows
you know tonight shows that Johnny I I
could I could break his chops man I I
could make him laugh i just saw i just
somebody just sent me one of me and it
was a picture of me and Bob Gibson
holding hands I love that picture
so that's that's the team picture so
Gibson was in on the joke the team
picture with the Hall of Fame pitcher
your your holding hands with Bob Gibson
who seemed like a very serious guy a
great friend as the guy shoot the photos
I just reached over and grabbed his hand
and we both started I love it we're
talking to Bob Uecker his 50th year with
the Brewers and and people should know
like you did have some legitimate
moments there you homered off sandy coke
Thanks yeah I mean that that's real at
Dodger Stadium right yeah but you know
every time I see him I apologize ma'am I
was really worried about that is that
why sandy doesn't do interviews is
because he gave up the home run to you
that's part of it yeah I I don't know
why I hit him fairly well I really don't
maybe was I don't know probably five
thirty said of his flock well you didn't
want those shadows if Koufax was on the
mound
that'd be troubled did you did you have
to audition for the role of Harry Doyle
in major league no you know I was doing
a game in Chicago against the White Sox
with the Brewers and and a security guy
came in he said there's two guys outside
want to talk to you so when I got up for
my innings off I went out in the hallway
at Comiskey Park and Chris Chester and
David Ward were there and they had this
script for the movie and asked me if I
would consider doing it so I said I'll
look at it which I was going to do it
anyway whether it was good or bad but I
looked at it read it and they told me
you know you you do whatever you want
you give the script do your stuff do
whatever you want and I did and I had a
good time you know I met a lot of good
people and the movie did good major
league to major major league three was
on airplane as a day after we finished
it was terrible yeah did you know at the
time when you did the first major league
that it was going to be good uh you know
it had some really funny stuff in it and
watching I met I met Charlie Sheen the
first night
the Bruins came back from a road trip
and they already set up County Stadium
for the movie and David asked me if I go
in and say hello to Charlie Sheen he
wanted to say hello so I went this
trailer and talked him for a while and
then when I watched him throw I mean he
threw pretty good he really did yeah and
watching Tom Berenger work
behind the plate and Steve Yeager
deserves a lot of credit for that too
because he really worked with with Tom
but you know the script was kind of
funny
I didn't use any big-time curse words I
was kind of shocked when I heard the
first one but other than that you know
they kind of let me do what I wanted
right I did their stuff and the name
they made the picks yeah great stuff in
there just just a bit outside with a
natural man I mean you know I'm doing a
radio game you're looking at a movie but
you know when you're on radio Dan you're
gonna do anything you want nobody can
see it were you ever a beer guy on the
air like Harry Caray was uh no not
really I was in - Jack - the team was it
dependent on how bad the team was that
year what you were drinking the team was
the game but I remember listening to Joe
Nuxhall and Joe Nuxhall you know God
rest his soul he had always say the old
left-hander rounding third heading for
home he spilled his beer on his
scorecard one night when I was listening
to him and Marty Brenneman and it was
just so funny cuz we don't we're
listening on the radio and Joe spills it
he's not he's not describing what he
just did and you just hear him like he's
mad and he's and it's you know Marty
Brenneman's trying to call the game and
then they eventually got around to you
know Joe had spilled his beer on his
scorecard there well they were there
they were a great team Dan I you know
what his name for me was Black Sea
remember but remember Blatz Blatz beer
oh my dad drank Blatz
yeah great team
I'm gonna miss Marty this year yeah
hall-of-famer on a serious note you know
this this virus here Bob yep how
concerned how concerned are you
well I am I'm I you know I feel bad Dan
for all the people that got furloughed I
don't care if it's baseball or anything
else people that I've worked around here
at the ballpark wrote for a lot of years
and and got furloughed and I I you know
I got furloughed when I was in the army
that was that was about it for me and I
was on our side do I want that but it's
sad when I when I see what's happening
we're going back to work on a very
limited basis my partner Jeff levering
and Lane Grindal will be totally
separated we all be separated by a big
piece of Plexiglas in the boot and you
know what our booth looks like in
Milwaukee so any engineer will be
separated from us it's I have to go in a
hole there's a whole different set of
rules to do this stuff you know you got
to be tested every other day I guess
matter of fact I'm going to get tested
tonight my wife and I and and our
trainer cap winger is going to do that
but you know I get I get a second look a
lot of times because I I go into a store
once in a while and I'm wearing my
catcher's mask I don't know if that's
approved by the CDC there well it saves
the pain from the punt because they're
living that saw me play do you think you
would have done steroids if they were
around I maybe I don't think so I don't
think so suppository amazing no not
steroid does your mic do people get
straight answers out of you that's what
I figured you've never been arrested
really
[Laughter]
well to be great to have you back and
thanks for just putting a smile on some
people's faces today you kids great to
talk to you
hello dang there and thanks to you thank
you buddy
that's a Bob Uecker mr. baseball there